omar i mean
you're part of the political class in in
your part of
the world where's the moral compass of
nowadays leaders
uh well i mean that would put me in a
bit of a difficult position of course
our leaders have the greatest moral
compass
out there um and you know i can't
comment on the moral compass in the west
but
that does seem to be a bit of cause
you're allowed to to come to
to comment on that but why not well you
know
i was going to say i'm not going to
comment but then i would comment okay
good okay
thank you it's just a little
manipulation and distraction
um we we look at
western countries and think where is
your moral compass where is your
backbone where is
you know you're standing up for your own
principle and there seems to be a kind
of a tolerance of absolutely everything
and uh
bending over backwards uh and and that
sort of
that worries us and so we you know and i
think that's had a
a kind of a a positive and reinforcing
effect
in our own societies where we've
actually taken control of
um very powerful narratives we've
actually we've got to analyze them and
to see
what are the forces that are driving
them what are they preying on and
you know clearly we in in the middle
east have greater control over these
public narratives and
and funding for it and so we're
attacking the funding sources as as the
initial point
um and um we we have um
been forced into a situation where we've
limited um certain kinds of narrative
because of the instability that they uh
induce and because of the
um the the preying on anxieties um of a
you know very traditional understanding
of islam colliding with
the modern world technology being you
know the
the greatest force out there so
uh i i in in a sense we
we never really took um a proactive role
in
defining ourselves um we were very and
particularly in the emirates we're very
small country
um we we focused on economic development
and making sure that we
the the finite resources that we had
could be well spent
now we've come to understand that
actually there is a life of the mind
that you know memes travel vast um that
social media has a great tremendous
effect and a destabilizing effect on the
the cohesion of our societies
um and so it's it's recognizing
the life of the mind and mental health
at a government level which is a massive
kind of break with traditional taboos in
the arab world
um well this this is um our
uh kind of beginning to to actually
acknowledge
anxiety as a mental state
but but why is that you lost your faith
in the western world
uh you i think we've we've spent so much
time in interacting with the west with
the us and western europe
and we've seen a kind of uh i suppose we
have
fairly clear ideas of ethnicity uh and
then we turn up in
in london and all of a sudden you can't
find a londoner or
an englishman in london you begin to
wonder well what's going on here where
where am i
um and you know we have a we have a uh
perhaps a manufactured and imagined sort
of sense of who we are
um but it's it's much clearer to to be
in the arab world than it is to be an
arab
in london